Mythos Mythos rufen sie ja ihr Messias
bolsonaro ist ihr Präsident und hält wie
ein Popstar feiern sie ihn
er ist ein Mythos er sagt die Wahrheit
ich kann das gar nicht erklären es sind
so viele Gefühle
das Land zu reinigen von Kriminalität
Korruption und linkem Gedankengut war
sein Versprechen Gott Vaterland ein
traditionelles Familienbild dafür will
er wiedergewählt werden
[Musik]
ich bin stolz darauf dass wir während
meiner Zeit im Amt dafür gesorgt haben
dass der Patriotismus wieder auflebt
doch Brasilien ist gespaltener denn je
seine Widersacher bezeichnet bolzenaru
als das Böse in den Umfragen liegt er
zurück und seit Zweifel an der
Legitimität der Wahl sollte er sie
verlieren
auch bolsonaros gegen Kandidat
Ex-Präsident Louis enasio Lula das Silva
weiß die Massen zu bewegen in seiner
Amtszeit fielen die bis dahin
umfassendsten Hilfsprogramme für die
Armen viele wünschen sich diese Zeiten
jetzt zurück
Lula bedeutet mir alles er vertritt das
brasilianische Volk Lola denkt an die
Armen er kümmert sich darum dass wir
genug zu essen haben
Lula als Kümmerer der ernsten und
Hoffnungsträger auch für indigene
Umweltschützer Minderheiten er will das
unterbolzenaro zerrissene Land wieder
einen
die werden den Respekt wieder herstellen
gegenüber dem arbeitenden Volk dieses
Landes
doch in seiner Amtszeit fiel auch ein
beispielloser Korruptionsskandal viele
Brasilianer Misstrauen ihm auch sie wird
er überzeugen müssen
AUA oh Leute das so noch nie waren in
Brasilien die Fronten vor einer Wahl so
verhärtet aus politischen Gegnern sind
Feinde geworden es geht um die Frage in
was für einem Land die Brasilianer leben
wollen und ob die Demokratie dieses
Duell übersteht
[Musik]
aus Waldo pasquallotto nimmt einen
Schluck Wasser aus seinem Fluss um uns
zu beweisen dass hier bei ihm die Welt
in Ordnung ist die Linken
brasilianischen Medien würden so etwas
nie zeigen
sehr lecker das brasilianische Fernsehen
zeigt nur Probleme und zeigt nicht
welche Lösungen wie auch haben wie
nachhaltig wir sind Gott sei Dank seid
ihr hier und zeigt es der Welt
aus Valdo ist einer der großen
agrarunternehmer Brasiliens er besitzt
100.000 Hektar Land ist höchst
erfolgreich und fühlt sich doch verkannt
Brasiliens Großgrundbesitzer seien zu
Unrecht als Feinde der Umwelt und
Zerstörer des Regenwaldes verschrien
dies sei eine Kampagne auch gegen ihren
stärksten Förderer Präsident bolsonaru
hat nie gesagt dass er die Abholzung
zulassen würde dass er den Wald kaputt
machen will im Gegenteil das Gesetz hat
sich in keiner Weise geändert die
Kontrollbehörden sind dieselben
geblieben die Propaganda die im Ausland
verbreitet wird ist falsch die
unterstützen bolzenaru zu 100%
Gott Vaterland und Familie steht auf dem
Aufkleber hier draußen hat er amtierende
Präsident die lokale Bevölkerung fest
hinter sich
wir sind im Bundesstaat Mato Grosso im
Herzen der brasilianischen
Agrarindustrie
der Regenwald der ihr einst stand wurde
schon vor Jahrzehnten abgeholzt jetzt
wachsen hier vor allem Soja und Mais die
Felder reichen von Horizont zu Horizont
aus Walde will uns zeigen dass auch eher
die Natur schützt den ganzen Tag fährt
er uns über sein riesiges Gelände
wir sehen hier immer wieder auch
Schutzgebiete denn das Gesetz
verpflichtet uns 35% des einheimischen
Waldes zu schützen wir fühlen uns
ungerecht behandelt schau hier ist noch
ein Schutzgebiet
Oswaldo ist stolz auf seine Arbeit
schließlich ernähre Brasilien die ganze
Welt
soja ist eines der wichtigsten
Exportgüter Kraftfutter für Rinder und
für die brasilianische Wirtschaft mehr
als ein Viertel des
Bruttoinlandsproduktes erwirtschaftet
allein der Agrarsektor aus Waldo
expandiert lässt eine neue Lagerhalle
bauen
exportieren viel nach China dort sind
unsere größten Abnehmer
doch das Schreckgespenst an der linken
zeitenwände geht um auf den Landgütern
Brasiliens
polsteraros linker Gegenkandidat Lula
macht aus Walde und anderen
Großgrundbesitzern Angst etwa wegen
seines Versprechens die Schutzgebiete
für indigene Völker auszuweiten
diese Schutzgebiete behindern den
Fortschritt denn wenn man eine Straße
bauen will muss sie mindestens zehn
Kilometer von Reservaten entfernt
verlaufen und alle 30 oder 40 Kilometer
gibt es eins wenn Sie die Reservate
weiter vergrößern müssen die Brasilianer
bald weg und nach Europa gehen das Land
wird zu einem Indianerland
in Wahrheit machen die indigenen Gebiete
nur knapp 14 Prozent der Fläche
Brasiliens aus doch solche Ängste und
auch Übertreibungen bestimmen in diesem
Wahlkampf den politischen Diskurs
verhärten die Fronten und werden uns
noch oft begegnen
am Nationalfeiertag Anfang September
beschwört der Präsident selbst die
Spaltung des Landes
wir wissen dass wir uns in einem Kampf
zwischen Gut und Böse befinden
ein Angriff auf die Demokratie
Trennung zwischen Patrioten und Feinden
des Vaterlandes führt letztendlich zu
einem stark geschwächten demokratischen
System in dem echte Argumente weniger
wert sind
indem die politische Unterstützung zu
einer Art fast religiöser Unterstützung
wird in der die politische Überzeugung
Teil der Identität der Menschen ist
seit seinem Amtsantritt teilt bolzenaru
die Welt auf in bedingungslose
Unterstützer und Feinde Wissenschaft
Presse unabhängiges Denken selbst
demokratische Institutionen wie der
Oberste Gerichtshof werden zu
Feindbildern
sein Gegner Lula wird seit Jahren
dämonisiert als Krimineller Kommunist
und Antichrist doch in den Umfragen
liegt der vorn und so äußert bolsonaro
ohne jeden Beleg schon einmal Zweifel an
der Rechtmäßigkeit der Wahl sollte er
sie verlieren viele seiner Anhänger
folgen ihm blind
einige dieser Menschen sind heute so
radikalisiert dass jede negative
Nachricht über den Präsidenten als Fake
News abgetan wird jetzt wird versucht
den Wahlprozess zu delegitimieren um das
Ergebnis möglicherweise in Frage stellen
zu können
international leidet das Image des
Landes weil ein bolsonaros Brasilien der
Regenwald brennt wie seit Jahren nicht
mehr die Gesetze zum Schutz des Waldes
sind zwar die alten aber unter
bolzenarus Führung wird der Raubbau kaum
noch verhindert die Gelder für die
Behörden die den Wald schützen sollen
hat er radikal gekürzt
seine Rhetorik Schuld Aggression und
Gewalt die sich immer wieder gegen
Umweltschützer und indigene Völker
richtet die Überfälle auf ihre Gebiete
haben in den letzten Jahren deutlich
zugenommen
und so tragen die indigenen eine
blutverschmierte brasilienflagge vor
sich her auf ihrer Demonstration in der
Hauptstadt Brasilien
sie fordern das Ende der Regierung wohl
zu Narro und mehr Schutz für ihre
Gebiete
mit dabei ist keritz Schuh sie ist
Anführerin des Volkes der goranie und
kandidiert für den Nationalkongress des
Parlament
dieser Kongress ist unser Haus das Haus
des Volkes
zurzeit sitzt im Parlament nur eine
einzige indigene Abgeordnete und das
wollen sie ändern neben keritz Schuh
kandidieren mehr als 150 weitere
indigene so viele wie nie zuvor
der sitzstopfer sind wir sind hier aus
allen Gebieten Brasiliens
zusammengekommen um diese Regierung ein
für alle Mal abzusetzen
die Fortsetzung dieser Regierung ist die
Gewissheit der Fortsetzung des
Völkermords an uns
angegriffen hat war eine Frau Mutter
Erde und wer die Erde angreift greift
alle indigenen Frauen an
diese Kampfansage an Präsident bolzenaru
ist eine ideale Gelegenheit für seinen
Kontrahenten Lula die indigenen als
Verbündete zu gewinnen während seiner
Regierungszeit hatte auch er eher wenig
für sie getan doch jetzt kommt er zu
ihrem Treffen und verspricht ihnen
scheinbar spontan genau das was Sie
hören wollen
[Applaus]
ihr habt mich jetzt auf eine Idee
gebracht wir haben ein Ministerium für
Rassengleichheit geschaffen wir haben
Ministerien für Menschenrechte und für
Fischerei eingerichtet warum also können
wir nicht ein Ministerium schaffen um
indigene Fragen zu diskutieren warum
sollten wir das nicht schaffen können
das Getöse der politischen Bühne liegt
keret Schuh eigentlich nicht wir
besuchen Sie auf dem Gebiet ihres Volkes
wenn keret Schuh im Wald nach Kartoffeln
sucht scheint die Welt kurz in Ordnung
doch der Lärm deutet es an
ihr Land wird durchschnitten von einer
Bundesstraße sie ist ein ständiges
Einfallstor für Angriffe etwa durch
Schlägerbanden die von landspekulanten
geschickt werden das Land der indigen
dass sich bis zur Küste zieht ist
es gibt einen Chor von Menschen die
behaupten dass dieses Gebiet nicht uns
gehört und die uns verfolgen wir können
also nicht wirklich das Leben führen
dass wir uns wünschen nämlich ein Leben
von der Natur
wohnt mit ihrer Großfamilie auf dem Land
ihrer Vorfahren um dessen offizielle
Anerkennung sie noch immer kämpft ein
Grund warum sie ins Parlament in
Brasilia einziehen will sie raucht die
pettingua die traditionelle Pfeife der
Guarani bevor es rausgeht zum
Straßenwahlkampf
dazu geht es in die nächstgelegene Stadt
Florianopolis obwohl auch sie in ihrer
Heimat liegt ist es für carith Schuh ein
Auswärtsspiel
Florianopolis eine alte Kolonialstadt
mit knapp einer halben Million
Einwohnern gilt als Hochburg der
Anhänger von Präsident bolzenario
guten Tag möchten Sie Informationen zu
unserer Kandidatin
ist bereits seit dem Morgen dabei
eigentlich sei sie zu schüchtern um
fremde Leute anzusprechen gesteht uns
kirit Schuh hinter ihrem Stand fühlt sie
sich sicher doch dort kann sie nicht
bleiben
auch wenn die Ablehnung die sie oft
erfährt schmerzt
[Musik]
danielisten haben ein Problem mit
indigenen und ein Problem mit Frauen es
gibt all diese Diskriminierungen
als indigene Frau spüre ich das sogar
dann wenn kein Wahlkampf ist
Schuh glaubt dennoch dass sie gute
Chancen hat ins Parlament einzuziehen
ihr packt mit Lula ist dabei nur Mittel
zum Zweck Hauptsache kein bolsonaro wir
sind in diesem Kampf um selbst an die
Macht zu kommen um unsere eigenen
Politik zu gestalten Lula ist unsere
Chance diesen Kampf fortzusetzen
Lula ist wieder da der 76-Jährige sieht
sich als das beste Mittel bolsonaro
aufzuhalten
von Anfang 2003 bis Ende 2010 war er
bereits Präsident in seine Zeit fällt
der weltweite Boom der Rohstoffpreise
und damit ein Aufschwung der
brasilianischen Wirtschaft
ein Teil der Gewinne verteilte er an die
Ärmsten
umfassende Sozialprogramme von Ernährung
bis Wohnungsbau konnten extreme Armut
und Hunger spürbar verringern
an diese Zeit erinnern sich jetzt viele
zurück die sich von bolsonaro
ausgegrenzt fühlen
erst wird diese Leute merken nun dass
sie unter Lula einen Job hatten sie
hatten Zugang zu Bildung
julia hat 40 Millionen Menschen die ich
die Unterschicht nenne zwar nicht in die
Mittelklasse gehoben aber immerhin zu
einer Art Arbeiterklasse gemacht
doch auch Lula polarisiert in seiner
Amtszeit fällt der milliardenschwere
Korruptions Skandal rund um den
halbstaatlichen Ölkonzern Petro Preis
mit Bauprojekten Geldwäsche und
Parteispenden kurz vor seiner erneuten
Präsidentschaftskandidatur 2018 wird
Lula persönlich angeklagt verurteilt und
inhaftiert allerdings unter
zweifelhaften Umständen der zuständige
Richter stellt sich später als
Verbündeter vom Gewinner der damaligen
Wahl Präsident bolsonaro heraus das
Urteil wird später aus formalen Gründen
aufgehoben offiziell gilt Müller als
unschuldig doch der Ruf korrupt zu sein
hängt ihm nach
zumal auch eher an den Grundstrukturen
Brasiliens die die extreme Ungleichheit
zementieren nichts geändert hat auch
Lula hat die Reichen Eliten Brasiliens
in Ruhe gelassen
nirgendwo werden die Gegensätze des
Landes so deutlich sichtbar wie ein Sao
Paulo die größte Stadt Südamerikas ist
auch der größte Wirtschaftsstandort des
Kontinents
sie ist
doch im Labyrinth der Bürotürme wird
auch die Zahl der Obdachlosen immer
größer rund 32.000 Menschen leben laut
offiziellen Zahlen auf der Straße
wir fahren zunächst an ihnen vorbei auf
dem Weg zu unserem ersten Ziel
das liegt im 25 stock dieses Büroturms
im schicken Viertel Brooklyn
dort empfängt uns Nelson Williams er ist
Chef der größten Anwaltskanzlei
Brasiliens und einer der reichsten
Geschäftsleute des Landes
und das zeigt er auch gerne er sieht
sich als Vorbild und Inspirationsquelle
für andere sein Brasilien ist noch immer
das Land der Zukunft in dem es jeder
schaffen kann der hart genug arbeitet
brasilien ist ein Land das viele Chancen
bietet ich habe dank Bildung meine
Chancen genutzt ich habe in Bildung
einen Weg gesehen mein Leben zu
verändern
Nelson hat sich hochgearbeitet vom Sohn
armer Arbeiter bis ins Herz der
brasilianischen Oberschicht
1000 Anwälte Arbeiten unter ihm 25.000
Firmenkunden suchen seinen Rat er lebt
den brasilianischen Traum doch dies
werde immer schwieriger weil die
Gesellschaft immer mehr
auseinanderdrifte sagt er von Präsident
bolzenaru ist er enttäuscht
wir hatten gehofft dass diese Regierung
mehr für unser Land tun würde das ist
eine rechte aber nicht rechtsextreme
Regierung sein würde
nicht eine Regierung der Konflikte eine
Regierung die die Gesellschaft versöhnt
statt sie zu spalten wenn die
Polarisierung zu politischen
Feindschaften führt nicht bloß zu
Gegnern dann ist das sehr schlecht für
das Land
auch schlecht fürs Geschäft gerade die
reiche Elite hatte bolzenaru unterstützt
glaubt mangels bröckelt diese
Unterstützung
politisch festlegen lassen will er sich
dennoch nicht er rede mit allen sagt er
und die mächtigen Politiker Brasiliens
suchen sowieso seit jeher die Nähe zu
den Reichen vielleicht ist das ein Teil
des Problems kein Spitzenpolitiker kann
es sich leisten sich mit den Reichen
Brasiliens anzulegen
und wie viel die den Armen abgeben
wollen regeln Sie lieber selbst auch
Nelson unter den Augen seiner
Leibwächter geht es mit dem Bentley nach
Hause in die brasilianische
Interpretation eines französischen
Chateaus in der Garage steht das
angeblich teuerste Auto in ganz
Brasilien filmt das sagt er uns immer
wieder
[Musik]
im Wohnzimmer empfängt ihn seine
Gemahlin Anne
[Musik]
die studierte Juristin leitet die
firmeneigene Stiftung diese leistet
rechtlichen Beistand und Bildungsarbeit
für die Ärmsten
für Anne Williams ist das eine
demokratische Kernaufgabe die die
politische Elite Brasiliens aus den
Augen verloren haben
leider ist der Wert der Demokratie bei
vielen Menschen noch immer nicht
angekommen denn gerade in den ärmsten
der Armenviertel fällt die Abwesenheit
der Politik auf einer nachhaltigen
Politik die aber notwendig wäre damit
sich die Menschen in diesen Vierteln
weiterentwickeln können
welchen Beitrag ausgerechnet Brasiliens
Superreiche wirklich leisten das
weitverbreitete Elend im Land zu
bekämpfen kann man diskutieren aber klar
ist der Vertrauensverlust in die Politik
zieht sich durch alle Teile der
Gesellschaft
vom Wohnzimmer der Williams in das
Wohnzimmer von Washington Haze
so nennt er seine Ecke auf einem
Sportplatz
da sind wir das ist meine Residenz hier
verbringe ich die Nächte seit acht
Jahren lebt Washington auf der Straße
der Alkohol habe ihn hierher gebracht
sagt er seinen Absturz verarbeitet er in
selbstgeschriebenen Gedichten
das Unsichtbare Haus
die Tür ist weg das Dach bleibt
ungedeckt
dein Blick streift nur die Straße
doch die Sehnsucht ist geblieben nach
Kindern Frau und all deinen lieben
Familie
Washington war einst Pastor einer Kirche
das Leben auf der Straße sieht er als
Läuterung bisher es aus eigener Kraft
heraus schafft zur Wahl geht er nicht
einmal obdachlos bist du nicht mehr
Mitglied der brasilianischen
Gesellschaft sagt er und die Politiker
würden sich eh nicht für Leute wie ihn
interessieren
machen immer nur Nothilfemaßnahmen um
sich zu profilieren etwas vorzeigen zu
können das reicht ihnen schon
Washington ist auf sich allein gestellt
um der Straße zu entkommen verkauft er
Kugelschreiber und Zettel mit Bibel
Comics 5 real umgerechnet 1 Euro kostet
das Set das ist recht teuer aber einen
Teil des Geldes spendet erweiter sagte
wir haben hier dieses Set mit Stiften so
bringen wir unser Projekt voran kannst
du uns mit einer kleinen Hilfe segnen
Bruder
nein kann ich nicht Bruder Gedanken dir
sehr gott segne deine Arbeit der Verkauf
ist eine Übung in Demut
hallo Bruder ich komme in Frieden geht
es dir gut einen wunderschönen guten Tag
wir tun hier an der Ampel das Werk
Gottes um unsere Ernährung
sicherzustellen für nur fünf real der
Fahrer gibt ihm 5 Cent ein Almosen
vielen Dank gelobt sei Gott
wenn ich verkaufe stelle ich klar dass
es keine Almosen sind keine Spende ich
biete etwas an ein Alltagswerkzeug bist
du ein Stift jeder benutzt Stifte das
ist mir wichtig dass sehr klar zu
trennen ich Battle nicht ich arbeite
seine Würde ist alles was ihm geblieben
ist und immerhin einen Stift verkauft er
dann doch noch
bis ins börsenviertel von Sao Paulo
dringend inzwischen die Zeltstädte der
ärmsten vor seit der Pandemie hat die
Zahl der Obdachlosen in Brasilien stark
zugenommen sogar der Hunger ist zurück
im Land ein Drittel der Menschen hat
nicht jeden Tag genug zu Essen auf dem
Teller
[Musik]
wir befinden uns in einem Krieg dem
Krieg einer Regierung der Reichen gegen
die Armen sagt Pater Giulio lanzelotchi
jeden Morgen bringt er Frühstück zu
Hunderten von Obdachlosen und die warten
schon hungrig guten Morgen Pater
guten Morgen
mach dir auch keinen Unfug natürlich
nicht Pater wir haben hier sogar eine
Bibel
Geplänkel das den Ernst der Situation
überspielen soll sie alle hier sind
durchs Raster der Gesellschaft gefallen
und es werden immer mehr
jeden Tag sehen wir dass das Leid der
Menschen zunimmt jeden Tag ist das Leid
größer es fehlen Chancen Perspektiven
für paterler sind die Menschen hier
nicht bloß Opfer einer wirtschaftlichen
Entwicklung sie sind Opfer einer
Ungleichheit die historisch angelegt ist
und bisher von keiner Regierung
ernsthaft angegangen wurde
abrasur Brasilien ist immer noch ein
Land der Sklavenhalter Brasilien war das
letzte Land auf der Welt das die
Freilassung der Sklaven zugelassen hat
und man hat sie freigelassen damit sie
vermengen man hat sie nicht freigelassen
damit sie die Menschen leben können
sondern damit sie als billige
Arbeitskräfte ausgebeutet werden
die Politik ist darauf ausgerichtet die
Armut zu erhalten
politische Programme tun immer nur das
Minimum damit die armen überleben
während sie langsam sterben
bleibt nicht viel mehr als Almosen zu
verteilen aber er gibt den Menschen
zumindest für einen Moment das Gefühl
zurück dass auch ihre bescheidenen
wünsche einen Wert haben
er sorgt dafür dass wir uns wieder wie
Menschen fühlen
er versucht uns wieder in die
Gesellschaft einzugliedern das ist sehr
wichtig
Vater lanzelotchi glaubt nicht dass er
noch erleben wird dass sich Brasilien
grundlegend ändert aber er hofft dass
die jetzige Regierung bolzenaru nicht
wiedergewählt wird sein Urteil über den
Präsidenten ist verheerend
es ist eine Regierung die sich nicht um
die Pandemie gekümmert hat die sich über
das Leid der Bevölkerung lustig gemacht
hat der die erschreckende Zahl der Toten
die wir verzeichnet haben egal ist die
die indigenen Völker zerstört die die
Wälder abbrennt die frauenfeindlich
rassistisch homophob und machohaft ist
pietra bertolazzi sieht das völlig
anders sie ist ein Aushängeschild der
jungen rechten Brasiliens wir sind bei
jovin Pan einem rechtskonservativen
Sender ins Sao Paulo gleich wird sie in
einer Talkshow über die Wahl diskutieren
letzte Vorbereitungen ich schaue immer
was die linken Medien sagen und wenn es
etwas gibt schaue ich was die Rechten
Medien sagen also November das ist aus
meiner Sicht der einzige rechtesender
als rechte influencerin befindet sie
sich im permanenten Nahkampf mit der
Linken mit Verlusten auf beiden Seiten
pietra wurde dein Instagram schon wieder
gesperrt nein das war ich selbst weil
mich so viele gemeldet haben das waren
radikale Aktivisten deshalb habe ich das
Profil selbst offline genommen weil ich
es mir nicht leisten kann gesperrt zu
werden
mehrfach in der Woche ist sie live auf
dem Sender das Ziel ist möglichst
kontrovers zu diskutieren das bringt
Aufmerksamkeit und damit Quote
es gibt immer gegensätzliche
Perspektiven auch von links weil ich
konservativer in gutes Stück rechter bin
ist für mich ein liberaler schon längst
dann gibt es immer Streit
wenn pietra zum Streiten kommt sieht sie
Gott an ihrer Seite ihren Rosenkranz hat
sie immer dabei
sie ist eine glühende Anhängerin von
Präsident bolsonaro jede Kritik an ihm
pariert sie mit ausgewählten Fakten
er hat sich doch sehr gut geschlagen
unsere Wirtschaft wächst das
Bruttoinlandsprodukt auch und unsere
Arbeitslosenquote sinkt
dass diese Entwicklung einen Großteil
der Bevölkerung nicht erreicht darüber
redet sie nicht wichtiger ist ihr
wogegenbolzenaru steht Petra spricht aus
was viele Anhänger denken der Kampf
gegen Lula ist ein existenzieller Kampf
gegen den Untergang ihres Brasiliens
es gibt Wahrheit es gibt Lüge Freiheit
und kommunistische Diktatur heute
besteht die unmittelbare Gefahr einer
totalitären Regierung von links
schon geht es in die nächste Sendung
hier spricht pietra über ihr Buch ein
Ratgeber für Eltern wie sie ihre Kinder
von linker Indoktrination in Medien und
Schule reinigen können für Petra ist die
ganze Welt von einer linken Übermacht
durchsetzt
von klein auf lernen die Kinder in der
Schule von den Organisationen der UNO
diesen Jargon von dem wir nicht wissen
woher kommt die Welt wird untergehen
Klimawandel all diese Irrglauben denn es
sind Irrglauben tut mir leid
wir gegen alle anderen im pietras Welt
gibt es keine Zwischentöne keine Fragen
keine Versöhnung weil es nur eine
Antwort gibt ich unterstütze Präsident
bolsonaro war für mich klar ist was
richtig und was falsch ist jemand der
bewusst den Sozialismus verteidigt mit
dieser Person möchte ich keinen Kontakt
dass die Welt auch im zerstrittenen
Brasilien von heute eben nicht so simpel
einzuteilen ist zeigt sich ausgerechnet
im Amazonas in Manaus viele hier glauben
dass es für sie und Brasilien nur
vorangeht wenn Sie den Regenwald weiter
Ausbeuten ihm sein Holz und seine
Bodenschätze entreißen es war ein
zentrales Versprechen von Präsident
bolsonaro dies weiter zu erleichtern
doch längst gibt es Alternativen wir
fahren den Rio Negro rauf in ein Dorf
das sich neu erfunden hat
1 standen hier in tumbira nur ein paar
Hütten im Schlamm es war eine ärmliche
Siedlung von Holzfällern und einer von
ihnen war Roberto Brito
ich habe Bäume gefällt um zu überleben
ich hatte keine Lebensqualität es war
eine harte körperliche Arbeit
doch dann kam eine Umweltorganisation
mit einem einfachen Plan nachhaltiger
Tourismus Stadt Kahlschlag nun bauen Sie
hier Ferienhäuser für zahlende Gäste
selbst eine moderne Schule ist dabei
entstanden für die Kinder eröffnen sich
Möglichkeiten die sie vorher nicht
hatten
noch immer ist es der Wald der sie hier
ernährt aber jetzt in dem seine Bäume
stehen bleiben
gerade ist eine Gruppe Besucher
eingetroffen einmal Dschungel und zurück
roberto ist ihr Reiseführer
ich bin kein Öko aber ich sehe was wir
hier erreicht haben denn ich kenne das
davor und das danach
Umweltschutz weil es sich rechnet
Indiana Jones für eine Stunde für die
Besucher aus der Stadt ist Robertus
Alltag im Wald ein Erlebnis genervte
Vogelspinne inklusive
früher hatte Roberto keinen Blick dafür
es ging immer um den nächsten Baum der
ihm etwas Geld bringen konnte Roberto
ärgert sich das Brasiliens Regierung
nicht einmal Versuche Umweltschutz und
Wirtschaftswachstum miteinander zu
verbinden
dieser Regierung die gerade im Amt ist
gebe ich bestimmt nicht meine Stimme nie
zuvor gab es eine Bundesregierung die
gegenüber der Abholzung
illegalen Bergbau und so weiter so sehr
die Augen zudrückt
ein Irrweg den Roberto nicht länger
mitgeht der intakte Wald bringt ihm mehr
Geld und ein besseres Leben
auf dem Rückweg zeigt er uns seinen
Lieblingsort
[Musik]
Frieden von Liebe
ich denke alle Menschen sollten
miteinander in Frieden leben
wenn ein Holzfäller sich mit der Natur
versöhnen kann dann können andere
vielleicht auch Umdenken
Brasilien ist zu groß wie ein Kontinent
seine Herausforderungen vielschichtig
und die Probleme nur lösbar wenn das
Land seine tiefe Spaltung überwindet
[Musik]